[موسيقى]
سكان الاصليونهم شعوب الامم الاولى
والميتي تنقسم هذه الشعوب الى نحو 50
قبيله تاريخيه لها سلالاتها وثقافاتها
وتنقسم الى اكثر من 600 مجتمع ولديهم نحو
70 لغه عبروا الى كندا قبل عقود وصاروا
اصحاب الارض يبلغ تعدادهم نحو مليون نسمه
[موسيقى]
سامسونج
نحن نعود للقبائل ونؤمن بانه لا يمكن
الزواج من القبيله الواحده لانهم يعتقدون
ان لديهم ذات الدي ان اي امي من قبيله
السلحفاه ووالدي من قبيله نهر بيت اما
اجداد فكانوا من طلاب المدارس الداخليه
التي اسسوا انفسهم فيها خسرنا كثيرا من
لغتنا لان اجدادنا لا يتحدثون لغتهم
الاصليه تبويس نحاول التقاط بعض الكلمات
من هنا وهناك حتى تبقى لكننا لم نتمكن من
تاسيس اللغه وتمكينها لذلك لغه انتهت
الله
[موسيقى]
احترام النار وايقادها في المناسبات
الخاصه قبضه من الطبق يضغط عليها في اليد
اليسرى ودعاء من القلب يتصاعد مع الدخان
الذي يحمل الدعاء الى الخلق لشفاء الروح
والتمني بحياه جديده
ماذا تعني النار
والى جانب انها مهمه لنا وسريه اصبحت اكثر
اهميه بعد ان اختفى اطفال
[موسيقى]
شركه فايروس
السريه الى 1800 عام نقد النار ايضا عندما
يتوفى احد الاشخاص